tout changement commence dans votre
esprit il y a de cela 15 ou 16 ans vers
22h j'ai entendu une grande agitation à
l'extérieur
il y a des gens qui étaient en panique
des voitures qui roulent très vite je ne
comprenais même pas ce qui se passe
quand j'ai demandé à mes parents ils
m'ont dit de vite me préparer pour aller
au village car la marée haute est bas ça
permet toutes les 50 minutes et que la
population craignait en dessous
la population avait peur et une grande
partie d'elle partez trouver refuge dans
les différents villages des hauts
plateaux
il faut croire que virement de la mer
dans le 6e
nous arrivons donc au village ou un ami
et je remarque que le village est rempli
donc toutes les maisons il y avait des
invités ce qui ne savait pas où aller ce
sont endormis sur des nattes à la
mosquée et au terrain de football
heureusement qu'il n'a pas pu
le jour d'après mes camarades de classe
ne parlaient que de l'agitation de la
veille et le professeur nous a dit que
cela a été dû au changement climatique
c'était bien la première fois que
j'entends des ce terme et je n'avais
rien compris ce jour-là
et le lendemain tout est revenu à la
normale
mais comme ma mémoire est très sélective
je n'ai pas gardé de souvenirs liée à
cet événement les amis qui ont suivi
par la suite j'ai quitté le pays et j'y
suis revenu disons plus tard
à mon retour
j'étais vraiment surprise de voir que
tout avait changé tout était devenu rare
les beaux oiseaux blancs et les
chauves-souris qui sautaient des arbres
les ânes qui se promenaient librement et
même les jardins en argile qu'on utilise
pour stocker l'eau ont été en place par
des récipients plastiques
dans la capitale le littoral était
rempli d'ordures principalement des
bouteilles en plastique
la population se plaignait de
l'augmentation des températures de
l'augmentation des moustiques du manque
de pluie
de la diminution des produits agricoles
les plus encore
je me suis demandé comment mon livre ma
belle il s'est retrouvée dans cette
malheureuse situation
le changement climatique a encore
résonné dans les oreilles et je devais
agir
cependant
toute action sont connaissances ne peut
mener à l'impact POS
itif j'ai donc décidé de faire quelques
recherches de m'instruire afin
d'acquérir certains connaissances avant
tout d'action toutefois le temps pressé
il fallait que j'agisse et vite mais
attendez je suis en train de vous parler
du changement climatique mais je vous ai
pas encore dit de quoi il s'agissait en
fait petite parenthèse il s'agit des
variations
caractéristiques climatiques à un
endroit donné à un moment donné
réchauffement pour refroidissement cela
a commencé il y a longtemps en effet le
temps a toujours changé sans
intervention humaine cependant le
changement climatique a été accentué et
accéléré par les feux de brousse
l'utilisation d'énergie fossile comme le
charbon le pétrole et aussi l'industrie
qui s'intensifie chaque jour de plus en
plus nous avons eu ce production nous
avons une surconsommation ces activités
qu'on dit en tropiques font de l'ordre
le principal responsable du
réchauffement climatique
bref le réchauffement la terre sans la
parenthèse vous savez lorsque nous
n'êtes pasons une vilaine grippe nous
sommes fièvreux nous avons le nez qui
coule notre organisme mais tout en
oeuvre pour éliminer ce virus grippal
pour établir l'équilibre
c'est l'analogie que je peux vous
proposer avec ce qui se passe avec le
changement climatique nous être humain
nous sommes les virus qui attaquent la
terre
nous avons rompu l'équilibre naturel qui
existait et maintenant nous subissons
les fréquentes catastrophes dites
naturelles
mais où se situe les Comores dans cette
histoire de changement climatique
j'ai découvert que comparé au bon pays
industrialisés notre production de gaz à
effet de serre n'est pas significatif du
coup comme une partie se prend pas à
grande échelle au changement climatique
les conséquences ne devraient pas être
si grandes que ça mais au fait non c'est
même pire que ça nous en tant
qu'insulaire nous sommes des premiers à
subir les conséquences du changement
climatique pour ne citer que le cas de
ma belle oui nous avons des rivières qui
sont asséchées nous avons une érosion de
nos terres dans mon village ou unani
personne ne dort en dehors de
moustiquaire vu l'augmentation des
moustiques
et nous ne prenons plus de bain chaud vu
qu'il est possible je suis là à vous
parler du changement climatique mais
vous vous demandez sûrement comment j'en
suis arrivée là qu'est-ce que je fais au
quotidien moi pharmacologue de formation
comment j'ai réussi à réaliser des
activités environnementales concrètes
dans ma communauté
et ben tout a commencé en septembre 2018
à Madagascar quand j'ai participé pour
la première fois
organisé par la Jeune Chambre
Internationale Madagascar
il cause noble d'envergure international
qui consiste au nettoyage de la planète
avec en 24 heures pour que vous vous
ce fut un grand événement et cela a été
d'une grande remise trois mois plus tard
je me retrouve au comment précisément à
Moïse à mon arrivée j'ai tout de suite
senti le changement négatif de mon livre
j'ai senti que je devrais réagir mais
que pouvais-je faire à mon échelle j'ai
essayé de me former de faire des
recherches mais le temps pressé l'alarme
ne cessait de sonner j'ai donc décidé
d'organiser le haut de climat day faire
participer mon pays pour la première
fois à cet événement d'envergure intern
la première chose que j'ai faite c'est
de constituer une équipe totalement
féminine composée de 5 merveilleuses et
talentueuses femmes trois jours après
nous avions déjà le premier jet de notre
projet
les jours qui ont suivi nous avions fait
les portes à porte de toutes les
institutions publiques ou privées les
associations ainsi que certains
particuliers existera oui
les réunions se sont enchaînées
mon équipe c'est agrandi ou sans passer
de 5 personnes à une douzaine de
personnes hommes et femmes c'est toi
les médias nous ont beaucoup facilités
en faisant gratuitement la promotion de
cet événement
des experts nous ont accordé leur
accompagnement technique afin que ce
projet soit une grande réussite nous
étions déterminés nous étions dévoués
pour réussir ce projet au début nous
avions prévu de faire l'activité
uniquement dans la capitale mais peu à
peu nous sommes passés d'un seul site à
3 ensuite à 5 nous avions profondément
cru à notre projet et le jour J nous
avions réussi à rassembler près de 1160
personnes nous avions nettoyé deux
plages et trois villages ce fut une
grande réussite et j'étais très contente
c'était le début d'une grande aventure
pour moi et depuis chaque année avec
l'aide de la Jeune Chambre
Internationale commun nous organisons
cette activité nos sensibilisons d'abord
la population sur les dangers du
changement climatique ensuite ensemble
nous nettoyons le site choisi après
nous étudions ensemble comment lutter
contre les déchets clandestine voici les
actions que je mène à mon échelle
jusqu'à maintenant pour pouvoir lutter
contre le changement climatique
malheureusement certains ne sont pas
encore conscients ils continuent la
déforestation les feux de brousse
il considère toujours la même comme
étant leur poubelles il brûle les
ordures à ciel ouvert son prix préalable
ils oublient que en tant qu'insulaire
les conséquences peuvent nous être fatal
es cela peut conduire à une extension de
nos espèces et une migration de la
population humaine pour chercher un
refuge environ comptable comme je l'ai
dit au début tout changement commence
dans votre esprit c'est une citation de
Billy Cox
j'espère que ce petit partage ça
contribuer au changement de vos esprits
et qu'ensemble nous allons lutter contre
le changement climatique pour un bel
héritage aux générations futures
je suis un chat Boubacar je viens de
mouiller
pharmacologue de formation mais une
grande passionnée de l'environnement je
suis membre de la Jeune Chambre
Internationale